chelsea football club's owner roman
abramovich has been spotted in public
for the first time since being
sanctioned over his ties to vladimir
putin he was seen in the vip lounge of
course at tel aviv airport where he
departed for istanbul on a private jet
it thought the billionaire then flew to
moscow
our home editor jason farrell is in
istanbul for us hi jason what more do we
know good morning
hi kay yeah well this is the first time
you've seen as you say that since those
sanctions have been put on him on
thursday last week in tel aviv airport
with uh wearing a face mask around his
chin getting ready to get onto his
private jet
to fly here to estan ball but he didn't
stay here very long he arrived in the
afternoon yesterday and then he flew off
to moscow in the early hours this
morning we understand so he isn't here
anymore um what could he be up to it's
quite an interesting question we know
for example that russian oligarch's
obviously trying to get their money out
of europe
he has a super jet which has been in
montenegro bay and i looked at where it
was last night on marine tracker and
it's now heading down the coast of
albania solaris that super yacht that's
worth 460 million pounds
which has a helipad and even its own
missile detection system is apparently
on its way here so was he checking out
places perhaps that he could uh keep the
yacht here but um we also believe that
he may have been trying to arrange some
of the sale of uh
of chelsea football club uh he has been
in talks so we can confirm uh with musin
bayrak who is
a
a businessman here he's a he's a he's a
turkish billionaire
um and we've spoken to his his press
officer this morning who says that he
did
meet with roman abramovich but not on
this visit last week and he has plans to
meet with him
again
so that is an interesting development
but obviously roman abramovich can't
sell chelsea football club because his
assets have been frozen and the british
government have made it very clear
that any sale of the club uh the assets
would not go to roman abramovich
but it may be obviously he started this
negotiations at the beginning
at some point last week and it may be
that he might still be continuing those
negotiations in the hope that at some
point he can get those assets back
this turkish billionaire made his money
uh in energy um he also uh
is involved in cryptocurrency um and uh
he also has development uh business here
uh in
turkish in a turkish resort
so
uh it is possible uh that that's
part of the reason why he's been
interested in turkey but of course the
world is getting much smaller for roman
abramovich and all of these
oligarchs who
are no longer able to keep their assets
in uh in europe it's not just the uk
europe has now also put sanctions on
roman abramovich
and of course he was in tel aviv and he
actually is an israeli citizen he's an
israeli and a portuguese citizen as well
and he does have
assets including a big mansion in tel
aviv and that has not been seized yet
unlike the mansions that he has
in kensington and the penthouse that he
has in west london he's lost those those
are currently in the control of the
british government